Okay, welcome to another Zoom call.
I'll open it up for questions at the end.
I want to clear up some information
that's been floating around the internet,
and the coronavirus using elderberry
with viruses, bacterial infections,
and the risk of some cytokine storms.
So I want to, I think that's a little bit
of misinformation out there.
We've got a lot of questions about,
should I take elderberry or give my kids elderberry
with the virus?
That's not a good thing.
You could cause a cytokine storm.
Let's talk about that.
So a cytokine storm is a hyper cytokineemia,
which is an excess flow of cytokines
and we're going to explain what those are in a second,
into the system and they can cause a lot of problems.
So a true cytokine storm can cause a lot of problems
for an individual and damaged blood vessel
and ethereal cells.
They can damage organs.
It could be really a horrible thing.
That's actually what takes place with many people
that have an autoimmune disease and are wrongly treating
their autoimmune disease in ways.
And we'll touch on that just a second.
So cytokines are part of your immune system response.
So the way your immune system deals with an infection
or a toxin or a food peptide or some sort of halogen
or what's called an auto antigen,
meaning something in your body that's then becoming an antigen.
So anything that is an antigen is something
that your immune system is responding to.
So an antigen is something that your immune system
is recognizing as an enemy.
Remember, there's two ways that your body
gets rid of things in your body.
You will detox chemicals out of your body, heavy metals.
Those shouldn't be recognized as antigens by an immune response,
however, sometimes they can
and we're not going to get into that in this discussion.
But usually an antigen is a pathogen,
is a biotoxin, a living organism, a bacteria, a fungus, a mold,
something like that that is now presented
to the immune system as an enemy
and the immune system's job is to kill it.
Now, inert substances like heavy metals
and chemicals and pesticides are your immune system
should not be presented to the immune system
and your immune system should not fire a reaction
against those things.
Those things go through detoxification pathways.
There's two ways that we get rid of things in your body.
You detoxify things, or you kill things.
You detoxify things through your liver, your kidneys,
you kill things through an immune response.
In the way that your body fires an immune response
is by creating cytokines.
So that's where these different named chemicals,
there's lots and lots of them, hundreds of them that come in.
But there's main ones here that we'll talk about.
IL-17, IL-21, IL-22, IL-2, IL-10.
These are all different cytokines
that fire different reactions.
And the purpose is that they help to present a bad guy,
a bacteria or a virus to your immune system
and stimulate immature immune cells that are called naive T cells
to then create macrophages and mature T cells
so that they will be killed.
So these pathogens can be killed.
That's the whole purpose.
So cytokines serve a very distinct purpose.
If you didn't have any cytokines,
you wouldn't have any immune response and you would die.
So cytokines are not bad.
cytokines are normal.
You have to have a cytokine response
in order to kill a pathogen.
So that's the whole purpose.
When we give a person immune stimulants,
whether it's to help ward off bacterial or viral infections
or to help the body kill cancer cells,
you are stimulating your body to make more cytokines
to make more T cells to make more mature macrophages
to kill that which we're trying to kill.
So a cytokine response is a normal response.
A hyper cytokine response is not what we want.
So let's talk about that.
So this gives you an idea.
You have a T-H-17 response, a T-H-1 response, a T-H-2 response,
and a T-regulatory response.
Your T-regulatory response is to help ultimately balance
this all out.
But when we have a hyper T-H-1 response
with no pathogen present, no cancer present,
no bacterial or virus present, we can damage cells.
When we have a hyper T-H-17 response
with no pathogen present, we can damage cells.
That's where we can have issues if the body responds
to heavy metals instead of something if you kill.
So then we have a hyper T-H-1 or a hyper T-H-17 response
and it can damage brain cells, brain tissue cells,
all sorts of bad things can happen.
So let's talk about that.
Here's another picture, good way to explain how your body
will react to an immune response.
These are all normal responses.
This is what you want to happen.
If you're not having this happen, you're in danger.
But there can be times where you could have
what's called a cytokine storm.
There's multiple reasons why a person
would have a cytokine storm.
And that's what's circulating around the internet now.
Don't give elderberry syrup
because you can cause a cytokine storm.
Can elderberry syrup cause a cytokine storm
in somebody that has a virus or a bacteria?
Very, very low risk chance of that happening.
So I think that's where it's a lot of misinformation out there
and you have to be careful.
You want to stimulate an immune response
so that you can have a healthy immune response.
So if you are exposed to any pathogens,
remember, go back to this picture here.
If you're exposed to any pathogens,
you want to be able to kill those pathogens.
So here's the pathogens that you're exposed to.
You want a healthy immune response
so you can fire a TH1 response and kill those pathogens.
So using immune stimulants is the right thing to do.
So this could be what a cytokine storm looks like.
And it's usually in an unhealthy person
or a person that has an autoimmune disorder.
So we'll touch on that.
So again, a normal cytokine experience.
You are exposed to a pathogen.
You fire, but your body makes these cytokines.
A cytokine storm is really when you make it all these cytokines
in excess when there's no pathogen there
and it can cause endothelial damage.
It could cause other organ damage
and that's not what we want to take place.
Actually, what we talk about with cancer patients
is they tend to be stuck in a TH2 dominant mode.
A TH2 dominant mode, if we go back to this slide right here,
is we're making way too many TH2 cytokines.
This is your B cell response
and this is not the killer cell response.
So the TH1 is really the killer cell response.
That's what we want to be in.
When we're stuck in a TH2 dominance,
then cancer can progress.
We're not stimulating a healthy immune killer response
and when we're not stimulating a healthy immune killer response,
then disease can continue.
Now, we have in this slide it says tumor progression
but we could also say bacterial infection progression
or viral progression
because the side on the left, this TH1 response
is how we kill things.
We kill cancer cells through that TH1 response.
We kill virus through that TH1 response.
We kill bacteria and fungus and mold
and everything else through that TH1 response.
This is how we kill pathogens, including tumor cells.
So if we want to stimulate a TH1 response,
we have to use immune stimulants.
That's why every single one of our patients
is on an immune stimulant to stimulate that TH1 response.
And that's what the immune,
that's what the rife is trying to do too
when it's trying to cause your body to fire in response
against those cancer cells.
When you run a viral program on the rife,
you're trying to get your body to fire in a immune response.
When I say a immune response,
we're talking about a TH1 response.
How do you fire a TH1 response?
You have to have your body make cytokines,
cytokines that will stimulate a TH1 response.
So this whole idea that's out there on the internet
right now that don't give your kids elderberry
if they have the disease
because they could get a cytokine storm
is really quite ridiculous.
It's like, yes, can you get a cytokine release?
Well, you better get a cytokine release
when you stimulate your immune system.
So they've taken information off of studies.
Okay, here's a study that black elderberry
will stimulate a cytokine release in a person.
Well, that's what makes it a good immune stimulant.
So that's what makes polysaccharides a good immune stimulant.
They're going to stimulate a cytokine release.
That's what makes anything that would be labeled
as an immune stimulant, a good immune stimulant
is that it's going to cause a cytokine release
and stimulate a TH1 response.
Now, when is it bad to stimulate a TH1 response?
Can it be bad to stimulate a TH1 response?
I'd say yes, it can be bad to stimulate a TH1 response.
So again, elderberry or any other immune stimulant
will stimulate a TH1 response
and it will stimulate TH1 cytokines
in order to help create mature T cells
and mature macrophages to help kill that pathogen
in order, whether it's the virus or bacteria
or whether it's cancer cells.
But when is it bad that this could take place?
The only time it would be bad to have a cytokine release
which we would then call a cytokine storm
is if a person has any history of hyper-histamine-like reactions
after any immune stimulation.
And who would these people be?
Well, I submit to you that these would be people
with a TH1 dominant autoimmune disease,
like phase three-line patients.
So let's look at this again.
Look at this picture, help you understand this.
Your immune system creates these different cytokines
that stimulate a TH1, TH2 and those other ones,
like we talked back here,
mainly TH17 responses.
So those responses help you kill different things
in your body.
Your TH2 is mainly your side of the immune system
that makes B cells and makes antibodies against these things.
But when we have an autoimmune disease
where we're stuck in a hyper-TH1 response already,
which is like an autoimmune phase three-line patient
that we don't give immune stimulants.
That's why it's all over my books.
When a person is in phase three-line,
you don't use immune stimulants
because immune stimulants are going to just stimulate your body
to kill that which you have antibodies against.
First, and that's the definition of an autoimmune disease.
So autoimmune diseases when you have self antibodies
and when you stimulate an immune response
to somebody who has self antibodies,
you're going to kill that self-tissue.
So you don't stimulate an immune response
to people who have self antibodies.
Now in my last book and not,
I took it out because it's a misunderstanding about it
in my new updated version is that I say,
cancer is really an autoimmune disease.
Well, technically an autoimmune disease
because a person doesn't necessarily have
to have antibodies against self-tissue,
but cancer is really like an autoimmune disease
in that most cancer patients are stuck in a TH2 dominance.
So what's a TH2 dominance?
It's when their killer side of their immune system
is working a much less than their TH2 side of their immune system.
So their imbalanced TH2 dominant,
therefore they're not making adequate TH1 immune cells,
macrophages, and T cells,
and that's why the cancer could progress.
So remember, why does a person get cancer in the first place?
Because something got inside the cell
and caused that cell to go into rapid replication,
possibly caused the blockage of the apoptosis pathway.
So it's not going through apoptosis,
not going through normal program cell death
and it's in rapid replication.
Well, shouldn't my immune system recognize it and kill it?
Yes.
Okay, so in every human being,
hundreds, probably hundreds of times through their lifestyle,
lifetime does this happen?
Something gets inside the cell
and causes that cell to go through rapid replication.
But if they're not in a situation
where they're stuck on a TH2 dominance,
their TH1, TH2 balance is sufficient
that they will stimulate a TH1 reaction
and therefore create mature macrophages and T cells
and therefore kill that growing cancer.
And then they never get a diagnosis of cancer
and they never knew that the head cancer.
So does everybody have cancer cells?
Yes, but if they have a healthy TH1, TH2 balance,
they're killing those cancer cells
and they're never getting a diagnosis of cancer.
But we can get stuck in a TH2 imbalance.
Stress can cause a TH2 imbalance.
So even going through,
so here's my episode of I'm, you know,
cancer is formed in my body
and instead of having a normal TH1 response
because I'm under a lot of stress.
I'm in a TH2 dominance.
Therefore I'm not getting effective maturation
of macrophages and T cells in order to kill
that growing cell mass
because I'm stuck in that TH2 dominance
because of let's say stress
then the cancer is able to progress and progress and progress
and now my immune system is not strong enough to kill it
and now I get a diagnosis of cancer.
So in every cancer therapy
that we use from a natural perspective,
just about every one of them,
we're trying to stimulate an immune response.
When we say we're trying to stimulate an immune response,
more specifically, we're trying to stimulate a TH1 response.
So that's the killer side of the immune system,
we're trying to boost up that killer side of the immune system.
Again, stuff that's circulated out there
about coronavirus, don't use elderberry
because it stimulates a cytokine reaction
and you could get a cytokine storm.
The chance of you getting a cytokine storm
from taking elderberry is really
if you have an autoimmune disease.
So if you have phase three autoimmune live
or you have a very serious autoimmune disorder
and you're trying to stimulate an immune response
to kill the possible virus that you're exposed to.
Yes, you could end up with a cytokine storm,
you could feel like a hyperhistamine reaction or worse.
So you do have to know if you have an autoimmune disease
and I would say, I guess the information of the internet
is right if you're in a phase three live,
you shouldn't be stimulating the immune system then.
So that's where you gotta use a knife
to kill that to protect yourself.
But we're talking with any cancer patients
or 99% of, you know,
probably 100% of the children out there.
Using elderberry syrup is a wise thing to do
to help increase the balance of your TH1 side,
push this side to kill any pathogens
that you might be exposed to.
So I hope that clarifies that a little bit.
That was one major question that we had coming in.
I will open it up now and unmute everybody
and see if you have any other questions that pertain to this
or anything else.
I did want to share this slide.
This is that what we talked about in that video,
the aerosolic acid, which is a new product
that we have in for cancer
and for viruses and immune response.
Super excited about that product
and then our clear immune plus,
which actually has now as a nice glass bottle
which is even nicer.
So any other questions?
Nothing.
Dr. Connor.
Yes.
I don't claim to understand everything that you shared with us.
But where do the thyroid hormones,
the TH3 and the TH4?
Do they play into this?
Okay, so let's not confuse this.
So a TH1 response is T helper cell one.
T helper cell two has nothing to do with the thyroid.
These are immune cells.
So T3 and T4, those are thyroid hormones.
Okay.
So your thyroid makes about 94% T4
that was in convert to the active form of T3
in the liver and the gut.
And T3 is the active thyroid hormone
that has nothing to do.
I know it's very confusing to do.
Oh, you think TH, oh, that must be short for thyroid.
Very confusing, TH1, TH2.
These are T helper cell one and two.
These are immune system chemicals, terminology,
not thyroid.
Okay, thanks.
Somebody had a question, a local clinic
was offering vitamin C and other drip infusions
with these be good for me.
And so vitamin C is an immune stimulant.
So vitamin C is a TH1 stimulant.
So vitamin C is good for viruses, bacteria.
Absolutely, very good.
Are they good for cancer?
Sure, can be good for cancer too.
Why?
Because if it's stimulated immune response, what is it doing?
It's helping to kill cancer cells.
So anything that you can do to stimulate an immune response
is going to help your body kill cancer cells.
But that's why people go, well, alternative cancer
didn't work for my friend or alternative cancer
isn't working for me.
Well, you do have to have a healthy enough immune response
to kill that cancer.
And you have to be able to get out as fast as possible too.
That's why it would be, I wish that an alternative cancer
was the first thing everybody chose.
And then they would choose to do standards of care
if they had to build up their immune system.
Because here's the sad thing.
What does chemotherapy and radiation do?
It just destroys all of this.
It destroys the whole thing.
And then you can't make your white blood cell count
is just in the pits.
And you can't make macrophages of T cells.
And how are you to kill this?
It makes it much more difficult.
I know that chemotherapy is sometimes important,
and you have to do it.
But you certainly want to then double down
and stimulate the immune response if you're going to do that.
All right, so hopefully this was helpful for you.
And maybe everybody's like, I didn't see anything
about elderberries or up in cytokine stores out there.
But there's a lot of, I think, misinformation going around.
And I think part of that was pushed by,
there's companies that, pharmaceutical companies,
for sure, that don't want people using any nutrition
for the virus and the video that I made yesterday
of the coronavirus and talked about the new products
that we have for that was, when I published that video,
I got a notification immediately by YouTube
saying that since we don't have as many humans looking
at these information, our computerized intelligence
will probably flag your video and it
won't be able to be seen by anybody.
Because you're offering information on the coronavirus,
it's just unbelievable.
So there's a huge suppression of information
that's going on that we're dealing with.
And they don't want people doing natural things
to stimulate their immune system, which I don't get.
I mean, they don't even, there is an idiot medication
that's valuable for viruses.
I don't know.
I think they just want everybody to be sick or something.
It's very sad.
But so just be careful.
You see stuff out there on the internet and stuff
even by functional doctors that maybe are fearful
and picking up wrong information and sharing it.
Bring it to us, not that we know everything,
but we'll certainly do the research on it and look at it.
Share it on the Facebook page, ask questions about it
so that we can try to clarify it and clear up anything
that's out there.
All right.
Well, you guys have a wonderful day.
Keep asking questions on Facebook
and sharing questions with us on the email.
Just please put it in the email location
that it's a question for the Zoom call.
And you guys, we will talk to you again next week.
Bye bye.